Let's look at the solution
to our MSI quiz.
Read X results in the same
behavior as in the previous quiz.
Both of them have the state as I, and
then when read X occurs in C1's cache,
it sends out a read request,
gets the block from memory, and now
it has the block in the shared state.
C2 still has the block
in the invalid state.
Now when C2 writes to X,
it sends out a write miss request.
It will get the data and
then write to its cache, so
it gets the block now
in the modified state.
C1 meanwhile transitions
from the shared state
to the invalid state because it
observes the write request sent by C2.
And then when C1 wants to write,
it does pretty much the same
thing as C2 just did.
It puts a write miss request on the bus,
gets the block,
writes to it,
puts it in the modified state.
Meanwhile, C2 has to intervene and
provide the data that C1 gets,
and then, because we snooped a write, we
need to transition to an invalid state.
Note that if a block is
in M state in any cache,
all the other caches have to have
that block in the invalid state.
If a cache has a block in a shared
state, all the other caches need to
have the block in either the shared or
the invalid caches.
So, pretty much we can have one has M,
all other have I.
Or we have several can have S and
the rest have I.
We cannot have M and
S in the system at the same time for
the same block, and
definitely we can not have M M.